hello welcome to this video this is
coverage for around six of the London
chess classic or the Berlin chess
classic someone yesterday's jokingly
remember marked well it's not so much on
this round it's we've got just one
Berlin in this round so you can be glad
about that I guess so let's see what
happened in round six we start with
Geary cards and give me one of the
co-leaders of the went with a somewhat
modest plus 11 win no loss um yeah many
drawers in this event but I think I mean
it is not a super exciting event that we
have to be honest about but lots of the
drawers have been coming from
interesting games so it's not that
everything was some just dull and
uninteresting okay give us on + 1 and
Carson the world champion has got five
draws so he definitely needs to win a
game somewhere but giveth black
difficult yeah we never lose anyway so
we'll see it we got a one-year form yeah
giri is playing all openings and so also
the roux is on the menu but it's a
normal normal line let's say normal with
a six not the berlin and an interesting
moment comes here cars and castles which
can mean that he's really ready to play
the marshal attack after on the possible
c3 md5 which he has done in the past but
not as a regular weapon or you might
just Bluff with castles and then play d6
and go back to a regular line in any
case Giri now goes d for that was his
preparation for this game d for as an
interesting sideline here and after
which black has a very principled choice
he can stay let's say on within grounds
of the entire marshal play something
unique with night XD for which can lead
to very interesting complications after
white can
check on f7 so very weird line but black
has very nice compensation in this
position or which is probably better
what can take and go 85 which leads to a
position with white having some
advantage space advantage at the center
something like this is even possible but
black has decent counter chance that
it's got a pond so this is an
alternative here for black but cars and
when to d6 this is the solid move and in
a way I think also maybe the more
interesting move because it doesn't
simplify the position now we get to the
so-called Yates variation that can also
arise from d6c three castles deform so
for white players this is an Universal
weapon that you can play against the
marshal move water and them regular move
on let's say okay we got this and cars
in lagos Bishop g4 pinning this night
putting some pressure on the center
Bishop b3 and now black goes for this
kind of operation winning a tempo on
their Bishop b2 also was hanging and now
c5 this is one of the main lines against
the eight system and and also what I
play with black I face this quite
frequently in blitz chess that d4 line
so we get this position in tnite bd2 was
played another way of playing this or
let's say here here and somewhere out
here white has the choice if he wants to
just continue to develop or if he wants
to play d5 at some point that idea to
play d5 I don't think it's particularly
effective here but just the general kind
of idea leads to a benoni type of
structure interestingly enough um and
this Quinn can get quite sharp
especially if white gets in age three ng
for it didn't happen in this game
because after Queen be 1g six Carlton I
took on deform and this is now a very
solid position for ya for black he's got
no particularly bad
night on b6 is in that workplace but
other than that the bishop 106 is good
d6 cannot put under pressure and whites
pieces also don't look so beautiful yeah
in the game we got a regrouping we have
one threatened f4 so black went back to
f6 and here white has finally kind of
untied his Queen side however after this
this there was an idea three an
interesting move to simplify stuff and
get rid of that night now black has a
very active yeah Queen and Bishop II on
that diagonal and I think this is enough
for black to have completely equalised
we saw around here they repeated a bit
but Geary um decided to play on with
Bishop t2i even got the bishop pair
after all but like as mentioned is very
solid a good thing for black is that his
pieces are nicely coordinated a queen
and Bishop are very well coordinated the
queen is protecting this and the night
is protecting this so it's a very very
difficult thing for watcher make any
progress against this kind of setup now
we had this straight and now after white
has to take it on c5 and go take a six
here they already could have agreed to a
draw but um they continued a little bit
without changing the assessment in any
way check in the final position here
when they agree to draw when the
position is so drawn that white would
even draw he's a pawn down what would
even draw if you just put the King on h1
and gives up both pawns it's still drawn
three free porns down this is how drawn
it is I mean just just for fun I'm going
to going to show that line panic here
here
the game it doesn't make any particular
sense i just want to show the general
idea we have the situation that the king
is here on a light square in the corner
it's the wrong bishop so everybody knows
that it is a draw with just those pieces
bishop only three and point h5 because
there's no way from black to get the
King out of the corner and there's
absolutely no difference see as there
are two pawns that you black and have
like six points on the edge file its to
the draw and here white can very easily
just wait until black goes see form and
then have the draw here yeah so it's a
total draw at the end um let's look at
the camera aronia next and see what
happened here yeah not not a Berlin
that's sure that's good but we got a
Catalan yeah the Catalan is a very good
opening for white quite clearly because
it is a it is solid it's hard to lose a
game but you will definitely win games
because you have often some kind of
nagging pressure this line with a four
currently assume is in fashion Aronian
goes with rook is six that is a move
that um yeah surprised is quite a bit in
the commentary I did the live coverage
yesterday for the ICC together with
Grand Master Jo Benjamin I mean I
probably should reverse that because the
joel is doing most of the work I'm just
yeah and the host for the show and um I
make the odd suggestion but he's the
main analyst yeah that is surprises that
rook maneuver but it's it's funny when i
checked it afterwards with with the
computer it's one of the main moves
given by stockfish so the computers is
also suggesting that somewhat weird rook
maneuver but if the root cannot be yeah
her rest anyway on b6 it's not such
badly place I mean detects a bond so
Queen we treated 97 rook to e1 and all
kind of normal and now Bishop a three
that's an important move Black has to be
aware that if white gets too
for then d 5 will put that bishop in a
in a difficult spot so you should just
give up that Bishop and then play see 6
and this is now a super solid structure
c6 d5 d6 f7 something that is well known
from some lines of the sloth defense or
the caro-kann in fact this could have
easily this kind of position could have
easily come from a mainline Slav wear
black has traded the bishop via g for
that same and get to the structure in
this kind of this kind of way um Quincy
to interesting moment if white goes
efore which you would like to do this
Knight takes e4 the typical tactic is
here here the queen is saying was Jack
so Queen situ in preparation for you for
and now after the night move this
straight happened yeah and here i think
blanket can already be quite satisfied
he's got rid of the bishop pair the
rukon b6 is not badly placed and he's
getting 'if Ivan yeah that maneuver
night eight to Quincy three it looked at
this this week ish pawn on a five but
black can cover it anyway black get c5
in and this is quite nice now wyd now
either has to accept that black gets rid
of the depot and gets possible squares
for his night oh yes to let black tea
Gandhi 400 capture with the pond and
that cannot be great this kind of
isolated porn so he decided to capture
and now we got this in this end game
position and yeah here we expected the
movie form in the sorry opposed to quick
the movie for during the broadcast and
we thought that um maybe why does a
little bit better because he gets in
Bishop g2 and therefore however we
didn't see a particular idea Bishop g2
and then g5 that is a very cool move
suggested by the computers
it's some pretty strong because F for
now is not good this is too weak and if
white cannot go F for in this position
it's difficult to make any suggestion
how to how to progress if Black gets in
like 96 possibly 95 he's in very good
shape don't underestimate that that
Queen side is rather weak be too as weak
and a4 is also potentially week so that
didn't give white anything that Bishop
gt4 idea he played to this move nothing
that we had on the Raider at all but
yeah attempted aronia to take it wasn't
necessary to take I mean black can also
continue with with moves like g6 and so
on but I think he concluded that this is
okay for him and didn't look so much for
alternatives yeah I mean b6 will win
that porn or in this case give black an
interesting pin on the D file yeah black
is definitely out of the woods and the
way it happened he now had this night c5
threat yeah he had a camera thought for
quite a bit if i'm not mistaken i think
it was this position yes and he went for
King g2 and after here we have this this
long check line that leads to a
simplification b3 night here in 95 yeah
now why the threatening to go with them
rooks e7 and there is not much that that
black can do 93 for further
simplification now before that's
basically the end of this game as a as
being interesting wyd now trades off his
final pawn them here he gets the bleep
on back they agreed to a draw right here
so we have two draws in those games
aronia nakamura
and geary carlson not very eventful but
you cannot really blame the players it's
kind of a kind of a normal thing that
sometimes happens black equalized with
an interesting idea or with with solid
play and not much happened all right so
let's have a look at mvl Caruana next
and in this game we got the Berlin but
this just this one this one game okay we
have the endgame check and b6 here
played by Corona what I'm what I learned
while looking at the database the main
move seems to be aged five in this
position nowadays this is also what we
had seen earlier in the event i must
admit that i have forgotten in which
game but it was played early in the
event b 6 is a different idea black puts
the bishop on b7 this is not something
that is so commonly seen in them in the
berlin as it kind of neglects the e6
square this is an interesting way of
playing e6 often is a problem for black
even with the bishop on c8 that the
position gets opened on the king the way
it turned out though in quran i was
playing very quickly as we as we see
here with the clock times um this was
obviously all prepared and when I looked
at this zone afterwards with the
database it turned out that this
position has been played before in a
correspondence game at least in one
correspondence game yeah part of koalas
preparation when MVR was spending them
quite some time already which is an
important factor later yeah so what
about this position Black has now this
key one of seven which is a little bit
insecure it can get to like here arrest
by by checks on the other hand Black has
gotten rid of this obstructing pawn on
e5
and if he gets to activate this Bishop
PA luck with c5 and centralized it
shouldn't be too bad we shouldn't be
underestimated that this knight on c3 is
pretty badly placed it looks at
protected squares on g5 and b5 and only
four so it doesn't do much on and on
it's probably a relatively equal
position but still something that is um
kind of interesting the next couple of
moves first they repeated this once and
then a form if what's interesting in in
regard that ok what is intending to go
a5f possible a five by black and this is
an interesting idea for them from
White's point of view to provoke the
move a5 because in some cases there
might be tactics related to the pawn on
d6 how would that work out let's have a
look I mean jeez most played now and
King here I just want to show you a line
that does not work at all but this is a
kind of idea that sometimes it's in the
position 97 check if black now just I
mean this is a really terrible movement
cause after King is six this is strapped
but the general idea is that if black
can go somewhere here then you can
sometimes take here because of that
insecure position now of the noise this
is only possible with a four day five
inserted even that isn't clear because I
hope ta hate that night has no square
but it is the idea that gets introduced
to the position with gaap flicking in a4
and a5 in the game check check f force
play here by an MDL and know that is one
hour down on the clock this is an
important part of this of this whole
thing um yeah what should like dunno i
think i wanna now plated precisely
played rock h2c 28 I'm sorry see 28 um
we in the broadcast we were thinking
that black probably would put the rukon
the D file but this isn't so great
because route d3 and a possible rook
d one later would introduce pinning
ideas on the D file or 94 @ saya you
don't want to bring yourself into a pin
rook to e8 instead what karana plate is
just stronger yeah now Luke t3 played by
MBL it's interesting that um now Kara
wanna had an active possibility that he
did not play he played the move g6 also
really quickly um I'm not sure it can't
really be part of his preparation it's
not completely impossible the thing is
the engine gives g5 and it looks a
little bit outrageous but it's it's kind
of interesting that move I mean not that
g6 is bad it's just that this is an
interesting alternative and it asks
right what is going to do next I mean
black wants to take that pawn and well
if you check here something this is not
not going going at um I mean white is
not in trouble or so but I mean
something like this for example is
probably turning out ok at the end but
it's still interesting to pose some
problems here for white um if we go back
here g5 what can go g3 but yeah I think
black is quite happy as he can use that
G file and if c5 comes hmm that's a good
diagonal so g5 looks interesting it's a
bit of a shame that g6 was played so
quickly um it's a solid move
everything's good but g5 was a bit more
interesting rookie one now that looks
normal support that night King g7 that
was the idea of the same and now nitey
form yeah white attacks that night on on
d6 and if black takes it group deception
is going to win for white so black had
to play this move and and now
interesting move by maxime look II to
d12
letting this night yeah be there for the
taking but black cannot take it then we
should can chat quickly yeah now
checkmate yep so that's not going to
work but black also if he goes back
somewhere here Brooksie seven is going
to win yes this is pretty awkward those
pieces are not I did paint them yes I
not really we're coordinated white gets
one piece back with a great position so
black cannot capture but he can go here
and then we still get this kind of
pinning situation on the D file that i
was talking about earlier yeah and now
the question is what what is why it's
supposed to do I mean he has a draw in
hand and this is with 95 and the thing
is he's got 25 minutes 4 415 moves and
what he did at the end he he did he took
that draw unfortunately we had this
repetition now for a draw so Ken white
continue yeah he definitely can I mean
if we go back white can definitely
continue but it's not that it is super
promising anyway what he could have done
is let's say let's say a move like h4
I'm just trying I'm just continuing here
so c5 may be freeing that 93 and then
let's say rook evade or so this is a
position that of course can be played by
white maybe he was a little bit yeah
concerned about his time situation that
he was down for down more than what is
it like 15 minutes this is well it's not
very comfortable no 40 minutes I'm sorry
no it's 50 we cannot calculate maybe
that was a little bit too uncomfortable
for for mvl here and he decided to ya be
content with the draw its little bit of
a shame that you could have continued
it's not like it's it's a dead draw
anything
anything like that it's um one of those
cases where I mean there are other cases
in the event way I think a draw was
completely justified but here what could
have certainly continued but the time is
a factor okay so let's have a look at
two part of atoms next to pile of has
have it has a really rotten event yeah
minus 3 and lots of unlucky games where
he could have drawn instead of using the
game win instead of drawing and so on so
let's see what happened here got a
Queens gambit declined and Bishop f4
yeah that's a line that I have some
experience with with both colors
actually so we'll get something very
standard h6 is an interesting move
normally black hair opts for the
immediate bishop moves but age 62 makes
quite some sense it's often useful
anyway and white now has no better move
than Bishop 23 in the first place so now
Bishop a6 gets traded and this is
basically how they play it with with
black this kind of setup and it's I mean
it's not the most exciting opening
anyway but it is so yeah sound and solid
it's something that I prepared a couple
of years ago four games in league
matches where um when playing strong
opponents and where I want some kind of
a solid foundation to start with and to
part of the idea here look night you
want and 92 is quite interesting those
nights have power set make sure that
there is no invasion on the AFR by the
rooks it's kind of interesting and he
then place in the center a quite an
interesting plan it seems that it leads
to an elite some some good fighting
chances and in them in the actual game
we see that Adams goes for that that
counter strike here with if I
in the center yeah here we expected a
bishop retreat in the broadcast bishop
h2 or Bishop g3 but two part of
surprises with just taking it seems that
he really was out for four or five TM
bishop h2 or so was about eco I guess a
TM that leads to an interesting kind of
position this 94 what widest tried to do
is it tries to pressurize those those
two pawns and on the other hand he 5 is
kind of weak can can be attacked and it
did gets gets very interesting now this
was played by Adams rook c1 and here he
decided to capture an interesting
possibility here was Bishop to a 3 it
looks them it looks am like 95 as an
interesting move now this is this
situation very tough to evaluate White
has 22 points for the exchange but black
gets an active group here that was an
interesting alternative Bishop e3 not
sure if to parlor would have given the
exchange when he really loves to do that
yes it's one of the most days is a
player probably the most the player of
the modern times where sacrificed most
exchanges um a most interesting but
Adams played in a more solid fashion he
took in played Bishop c5 I think that's
also not a bad decision at all yeah he
simplified regroup the night and had a
look at those pawns there are also some
targets so those are targets but of
course those pawns are not an easy to
play with as well note that white cannot
take on d5 and due to the pin on the D
farm yeah this was played just doubling
on the C file
this and now Luke a6 was played yeah and
this is probably not a good idea if
black I was 97 here to cover that he's
probably slightly worse i mean i would
really prefer whitey a little bit
because his six is easier to play
against then air form but it's not a
matter of yeah good or bad is just what
you had to do what Adams played him and
had a big drawback okay 694 he went now
97 yeah and now might be three was
played and this is the the biggest
family for area family is wrong with one
Queen one rook and another look and this
is an interesting thing if you threaten
a fork on three heavy pieces it's
impossible to avoid yeah I mean you can
only move one of them away and as Adams
later admitted he had completely
overlooked that possibility and it's a
very human move to overlook because the
night is so nicely placed on d4 putting
pressure on c6 covering f5 it doesn't
feel right to retreat it but well if it
wins material if it's of course right
and here this is just winning the
exchange so to follow Brett that
exchange played g3 f4 was hanging so it
makes lots of sense now a g5 black needs
counterplay if you just sit there doing
nothing he will just be the exchange
down and here why it is basically forced
to take take an outer part of play
droopy one it took about five minutes
here he had 30 minutes on the clock um
and it turns out that this is the second
critical position of the game the first
being they have the one where to pile of
gave they exchange oh and sorry we're
Adams Adam some yeah gave blundered the
exchange rookie one it looks like the
most normal whatever but it seems that
it is a mistake
but this is a very very tough to see
beforehand how tricky it gets after
after this move it seems that one of
them the computer suggestions like Queen
c3 or queen III that cover the pawn a
better but it's very difficult it's
really very difficult to see why looky
one should be bad we will see what
happened rocky 196 and the thing is this
is attacked of course and it's very
difficult for white to a yeah and to now
just protect the porn how would you do
it how would you do that if you play
Queenie to for example then black won't
take any way and said Lucas hanging and
the 90 only five now is absolutely
fantastic it covers here and in a taxi
which is the most important thing this
is even possible as that's always the
Queen on c2 it's really awkward now how
do you cover that two part of um relied
on on and move he was certainly thinking
that he wins with this is 6ft x Roxy six
this is what happened but now 95 and
what are you doing now it hangs and this
Hanks and it's again it's a huge fork in
in both earn on both sides we have big
Forks this is hanging this is hanging
and with it the whole position it's
really really crazy and then the
craziest part is that now I mean the
most obvious let's say move first move
that comes to my tea is root 2 xe5 I
think Queen takes check check and King
somewhere makia to f7 I don't know
something like that it's that if what
let's say it goes here yeah and this
looks terrible as Queen h7 the Rope here
this King is kind of insecure that black
is just playing the super common King g7
and it seems that there is nothing that
white can
it's really funny czechia black goes up
and white okay white can always draw by
taking the rook but that is an immediate
draw it's a perpetual on on white skin
it's an amazing situation why it has
absolutely no way after 95 to ya to
travel black that is just an amazing
amazing threat to part of Chatham the
check and try drew gave one but this
after China takes again is then it's no
way of winning White had to take Queen
takes and Queen see to that is what he
tried again angling for four checks IAM
and attacking the rook but black is just
calmly playing King g70 we know that
idea already and it's really funny White
has no way forward if he just check here
black just steps up and here white has
no checks okay he's got that check but
then I go deform and this is the
situation where white I mean probably
early armored here you definitely start
to worry with what your pawn down and if
you don't have a maid or some kind of
decisive action against the king how are
you going to continue that game so it
was really am it was a shame for the
part of he had to take that rook and
check except the draw so he really has a
bad event sometimes you you just I in
some kind of tournament where nothing
ever yeah yet goes right for um whatever
you do it is kind some kind of drawbacks
of miracle escape some kind of weird
resource that you did not see and you're
not winning this after enemies blundered
the exchanges Sam is a big shame um so
yeah this was the moment rookie won its
most normal move ever but it seems that
it really gives away have a point okay
so we've got the fourth draw here in a
row in that event this round so let's go
to the fifth game Greece Oak Island so
let's see once you form so noble in yeah
and in fact no theoretical discussion at
all as Grisha guess it's just talking to
d3 yeah this has no particular point or
anything it's just a move that says okay
let's just play some some chest let's
not play some kind of preparation yeah I
learned pretty quickly decided to play
this set up every burst Grand Prix um
yeah this is not a bad choice the most
dangerous weapon set weapon that white
has against it setup is an early deform
and now well with d3 already being
played that is kind of out of the
picture I'm talking about things like
this for example this is something that
why definitely likes to play and the way
and that gave me unfolded it makes no
sense at all for why to play d4 so f5
it's not a bad move so all that is kind
of normal channel check on before so
black gets this Bishop traded check and
then place d6 we are very logical trade
that bishop and then put the pawns on
dark squares so that this is a decent
piece the bishop only seven let's say it
would just be bad so all that is kind of
normal and now Grisha pens night went 95
yeah here and I decided to capture that
night and to capture that knight on d5
wasn't term it wasn't forced or anything
but it's always a little bit annoying to
have that have that piece on d5 I think
are not wanted some some clarity of the
structure this this and here I mean
there are some interesting alternatives
now for white if you go let's say rook
see one and then
blackened can try c6 try to get a
position a position like that where I
think black has nothing much to fear
agree shook tried something interesting
he played Queen to before that's a very
direct move attacks that porn on b7 and
yeah interesting moment now for black he
had a couple of alternatives but
ultimately decided to to take that pawn
on d5 it looks risky at first because
why what can set up on set up a pin
however bishan b6 is saving the day here
white can try a 95 for example but this
is at the end J not leading to anything
this is just completely equal so this is
why Grisha took on b7 this is the more
interesting move c6 basically had to be
played and now White has to hear ninety
to ninety six now White has to worry a
bit about the Queen Queen only has one
square on a 60 he steps out before
something bad happens yeah so what about
this position um I actually thought
during the broadcast that why it is
slightly better because those pawns look
weak c66 they look a little bit weak and
white some yeah I think white has a
little bit of pressure against those
pawns in the game on a 25 that's the
tough decision to play that move because
you we can see 585 quite a lot but maybe
you had to NC six was under some
pressure I think that black is probably
ok but there is one particular moment
where I think I that goes wrong kiya
Jade that was an interesting moment here
g5 for them suggestion during the
broadcast and I think that it's kind of
interesting that move Black is just yeah
just going for it on the King side
um during the broadcast actually thought
that white is better after d4 but maybe
that is not true Teague's and then Queen
back and that that pawn looks like it
falls and if what gets that pawn just
like that you also has an advantage sg5
has mostly weakened black skin King
position but rupee adis I'm sorry that
was wrong ook eh is a decent alternative
now because if 94-94 is quite annoying
now White has no good square now for the
Queen really yeah ok can go to see three
but this is not not very exciting for
what maybe g5 was an alternative it
wasn't bad it seems King age eight is
kind of whom don't know what to do move
b3 and now the next move is definitely a
mistake by an auntie goes Bishop g4 and
after that it seems that white
definitely has an edge Queen co3 now
this is a double attack against those
pawns and black now whatever he does now
he would have some sort of disadvantage
I think he probably should have taken on
f3 that's the the best term the best
option now even though after this white
is still a little bit better of course
you know those pawns are against more
week more weakness than any kind of
strength and white has ways to to
pressurize them some Queen 85 looking at
that point for example a couple of ideas
and in general you don't like to give
that Bishop there against the knight on
f3 but it probably had to do it this is
what Allen played but after antiques
takes 90 for white now has a pretty
substantial advantage that is very weak
and the knight on d4 as a fantastic
piece he may be relied on this then f3
move that now the bishop is bad here on
h1 but this is just a temporary thing
while this is permanent we will see what
I'm talking about before yeah fixing
that weakness let a form and after
this we see that white is able to force
a trade of H pawn against F pawn and
tell this is a pretty terrible end game
for black c6 is just completely week and
there is no compensation for that in the
game it it really turned out to be yeah
super uncomfortable this was played
deform we shall catch little time so he
had to play a play quickly yeah night c4
is an interesting try here by huh not
posing problems wants to get rid of this
night only five and this is what
happened it's a born of course yeah
Black has given up upon but he has some
activated his position quite a bit so
group c 50 d for a check yeah so let's
have a look at this end game from here
yeah why does a pawn up and it's got the
better structure so it should be a
straight win for a while however things
are not not that easy during the
broadcast we had huge problems in really
proving a wide win and it turns out that
in the game it also got very tricky I
mean white has a couple of alternatives
along the way but let's have a look what
happened here Bishop t5 threatening mate
this this yeah and now White has no big
choice he has to take and this is a very
interesting endgame it looks like a
total simple wind why does a pull-up
better structure this is about to fall
but what we should not underestimate
black is active where the king is coming
in to e4 and the deep on is running it's
not easy at all rook a 7 now + d 4 and
we can be absolutely could not prove a
win during the broad
and it also looked at this a little bit
with the computer afterwards and I also
couldn't come to a clear conclusion if
this is a win for wide or a draw I mean
it should be a win but all kinds of
bye-bye on general grounds or whatever
you may call it yeah I mean it's hard to
believe that black should be able to
draw but he definitely has chances to do
so we we can ever look at a couple of
lines here a one line that we looked at
in the broadcast was white pushing the a
porn and I think white has winning
chances here but it's very difficult to
get to a conclusion as I said a five
here a six this kind of this kind of
variation is surprisingly tricky for
black now here in this line white gets
to this end game and to be honest I'm
not entirely sure if if this is um if
this is a draw or win maybe if you are
an endgame expert and have time on your
hands please let me know I'm not one
hundred percent my time is a little bit
limited for that video so I didn't want
to invest like an hour or so to figure
that out maybe it's easier to figure out
and then you just can't just know that
the answer but I wasn't sure um and I'm
not sure that the line that leads to it
is entirely force but that was an
alternative for white the thing is that
the way it was played there was one
moment where Alan definitely could have
drawn it's kind of it's really funny um
in the in the game Grisha played b5 also
the the more normal move let's say would
be to and now a force plane after that a
lot can draw he absolutely is able to
draw this game um um instead what what
is an alternative let's say and I looked
briefly at rugby seven here d three
six rupee 1 preparing d2 d1 um let's say
check check 72a for ya the funny thing
is that it's all about this thing check
ya King up this and I think this is a
draw black should be able able to draw
this by some kind of counter attack on
the White King but again this is
something that I'm not one hundred
percent sure about black and also
instead of like here ad to a four you
can also do this first maybe this is the
why is the decision to try to attitude
to try to trade all that white white
take because I think here the chances
for a draw somewhat somewhat higher yeah
it's it's a very it's a very tough tough
endgame but it's interesting to see that
that normal move a form that in fact is
a draw amazingly enough it just said
Allah didn't find it yeah and unplayed
to move from King d3 and d3 seems to be
a draw even though it's hard to believe
but it's just what that's the result of
of looking at this with the computer and
the computers is if you look at this a
little bit i mean the human combined
with the computer here leads to an
almost perfect evaluation because you
have the pure of calculating power of
the engine and you have the human
looking at a couple of critical
positions where the engine sometimes is
not one hundred percent one hundred
percent correct because it doesn't see a
particular kind of fortress or things
like that so um yeah i think this is a
draw b6 group b 1 also stockfish things
it's the draw I mean that must be must
be a correct there yeah this is some I
think ultimately I'm sorry that was the
wrong move
I just screwed up my my notes and b6 a4
d3 yeah b6 just gets taken of course
it's roped itself and I'm sorry Rock d7
yeah and now just move like this and
it's quite funny what is why it's
supposed to do now yeah if you move one
of the pawns it just gets taken you
cannot activate the king in any way so
what is your move it's very it's very
strange um you can look at various ways
to give up one of those pawns but it
doesn't lead lead to anywhere if wide
White's is doing that black let's go
here and again you cannot move one of
the pawns it's really weird I don't see
how I can make any any sort of progress
here if you give up this pawn let's say
I'm taking this andrew k5 I don't see
how how how this is a win it's quite
quite funny after d3 it seems to be a
draw at least that's what the computer
say okay but all I didn't do that he
played King to d3 rugby 7 Luke a 2 and
now be 6 this is the problem in this
position Black has no defense anymore i
mean the king is blocking his pawn so
now um after let's say rook before white
goes b7 and this is the problem the King
cannot move there's always a check and
the promotion and this means that black
can just stay and now white just brings
the king this here and there form and
that's the end of it it's basically a
Supes one white will win this so it
wasn't I mean it's still slightly
mysterious because King III very clearly
losers so you should have to you just
have to try the three
um and it was a draw funny enough very
very very very tricky ruga endgame down
that if you have some time on your hands
you can definitely explore deeper than i
did now in that term in that video okay
i hope you enjoyed the coverage here of
round six the overall standings are
quite funny we've got four players with
plus one we shook mvl Nakamura and geary
then a bunch of people with fifty
percent others on minus one and two
polymers and minus three so even with
just three rounds to go basically
anybody can win the event and round
seven seas the game console Nakamura one
of the modern classics let's see if the
world champion can win against his yeah
maybe not why I'm not sure it's of his
favors opponent but Nakamura has a
terrible score against cards never won a
classical game so let's see what Magnus
can do them okay well thanks for
watching